thank you
mommy children outside the emergency
field Hospital in boy Vista the capital
of the northern state of horima
these are the lucky ones rescued in time
from the ongoing Health crisis in
Brazil's largest indigenous territory
both old and young Yanomami have been
dying in their Villages from hunger and
disease despite living on protected land
the size of Portugal in the heart of the
Amazon rainforest
the onslaught of illegal mining has
polluted our rivers with Mercury
destroying our forest and livelihood we
cannot fish we cannot drink water we
cannot bathe without getting sick
is responsible for indigenous Health
every day he receives shocking pictures
from the Yanomami villages in Desperate
cries for help
like this one from a man who walked four
days in the jungle to send an Urgent
Message
there are five children who are so sick
they can't even walk he says send us a
helicopter we have no medication to
treat here nothing
helicopters are being sent to take
supplies rescue the sick and chase away
the illegal miners but this is something
new during the past four years former
president jayapo sonaro has ignored and
even encouraged the invasion of
indigenous territories
there were many reports that a
humanitarian crisis was underway but the
former government dismantled the
organization in charge of protecting the
rainforest and the indigenous people we
knew what was going on but were not
authorized to act as we should now that
has changed
in the last two weeks there have been
daily flights to destroy equipment used
by the illegal miners
all of these helicopters and small
airplanes that you can see here have
been used to take supplies Fuel and food
to the illegal miners in the Yanomami
territories now they have been
apprehended by the federal police and
are shown as proof that they're much
larger interest at stake and that
somebody has been financing this whole
illegal gold mining operation
removing the Invaders is only the first
step the biggest challenge will be to
keep them out and clean up the rivers
they have destroyed Monica and akiv Al
Jazeera boavista Brazil